hey yeah I'm 2017 kind of got away from  me but this is the year that I really  want to get in shape you came to the  right place  first thing what's your diet been like  late I mean I've only been in dub use  well sometimes I have know before bed  maybe in the morning or during prime  time okay sign here wait with all the  other eliminated players who decided to  join a gym on January 2nd I'm gonna make  some changes in 2018 yeah we're gonna  make some changes to this is where all  the cardio goes yeah how does this work  over here we have a bunch of giant tires  terrible for your back but great this is  our spa wellness area perfect for rehab  whoo-hoo these jets are okay cable  machines and of course bench prior whoa  I'm in let's get started Hey